للمره الثامنه منذ مارس 2022
رفع البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي سعر الفائده
التضخم والازمات تضرب اقتصادات العالم ضبط
سعر الفائده جزء من مواجهه الازمات بجانب
تعديل متطلبات الاحتياطيات لدى البنوك
وبجانب امر اخر طباعه النقود تضطر اليه
البنوك المركزيه في بعض الاحيان من اجل
التحكم في المعروض النقدي والذي يؤثر بشكل
مباشر في معدلات التضخم ومستويات الاسعار
في الولايات المتحده وفي عام 2020 مثلا ضخ
الفيدرالي الامريكي تريليونين و300 مليار
دولار من اجل تخطي تداعيات ازمه كورونا
لكن ماذا تتصور ان يكون شكل التريليون
دولار
التريليون دولار يمكن ان يغطي البنك
الفيدرالي بالمعنى الحرفي وهو المكون 12
طابقا حيث اجمالي مساحته
203000 متر مربع
لكنها طباعه هذه التريليونات امر مكلف
مليار دولار هي تكلفه طباعه الاموال في
امريكا العام الماضي تخيلوا الرقم طباعه
الاموال عاده لاي دوله لديها عمله خاصه
امر يؤدي للتضخم والهويه الاقتصاديه لكن
امريكا لا تتاثر مثل كل الدول وذلك بسبب
مكانه الدولار في النظام النقدي العالمي
فالعمله الخضراء هي الجزء الاكبر من
احتياطيات جميع البنوك المركزيه
حول العالم